and we do now have audio from the Las
Vegas police department of the moments
when officers breached pattex room I
need everybody in that hallway to be
aware if I didn't get back we need to
pop this guy the audience on the 32nd
floor
what has explosive breach everyone in
the hallway needs to move back all units
move back breach breach breach one
suspect down and 1 3 5 4 32 Mandalay Bay
I have the floor under sheriff Kevin
seebik may Hill with the Las Vegas Metro
Police joins us on the phone
undersheriff thank you so much for
joining us as we just heard from that
audio as soon as police stormed the room
they knew that the gunman had been dead
and it from a self-inflicted wound
correct yes you are correct can you talk
more about what the police discovered in
his room there were 10 long rifles guns
that were reported to be found yes you
know as we sit here today right now as
we're speaking we have just recently
obtained the search warrant for the
suspects room we have made entry into
the room and we are now of course one of
the things in these types of
circumstances then you have to watch out
for is booby traps to rob horses so yes
they do a very slow and methodical in
that room I can confirm to you that
there are at least 10 rifles some
spotting scopes that go along with those
rifles and there's a lot of other stuffs
in there but it's pretty mature for me
to tell you exactly what it is yet
because I don't know either but I can I
can't confirm to you that there are many
expended rounds as well as rifles and
ammunition in that room Kevin may
Helmick male what can you tell us about
the circumstances listen just listening
to that audio I thought it was extremely
dramatic we have heard from other law
enforcement officials that people were
led to the room because they saw the
muzzle flash other people say they were
led to that room because the smoke
detectors went off
and it was creating a loud disturbance
can you tell us what exactly led your
team to that room yeah I have not yet
heard the piece on the smoke detector
but that certainly could be true I do
know that there were a number of
officers across the street at the event
that was taking place they were able to
actually hear around and fired as well
to look up and see that the suspect is
firing from particular 32nd floor of the
Mandalay Bay so a number of responding
officers went over there immediately
there was a lot of confusion as you can
imagine so it took a little bit to get
to that room what a students are there
wherever isolate that room and identify
it they did an immediate explosive
breach I went in and he had shot himself
Kevin how many rounds do you believe the
shooter got off yeah I really don't know
but I can I I would have to guess it has
to be in the hundreds with the amount of
people that are both dead and wounded we
continue you know just about every hour
that goes by we continue to get notified
of individuals that self transported to
hospitals every one of our local area
hospitals is pretty much maxed out as
far as their casualties and so they
continue to to look at that I can tell
you along with that there were a number
of the Police Fire EMS worked very well
together here at this event
and they also had a number of civilian
that would just pick people up in the
vehicles and Jonathan right over to the
hospital and so we have a lot of that
stuff dispatching self transport to area
hospitals as well and so I you know the
numbers are gonna continue the flux
fluctuate in the coming hours and I
think we'll be able to have this late
this afternoon
have a better idea of the entirety of
those dead and injured did he did he cut
out the window in the hotel room did he
did he shoot it what happens
I believe what I've been told at this
point is that been shot out through the
window so that was out how he'd ever get
there imagine his vantage point Billy
would set
to what he was looking at specifically
across Las Vegas Boulevard you know open
air environment there are 23,000 people
who attacked him enjoying a concert
before he unleashed his carnage do we
know if he checked into the hotel under
his name yes what can you tell us Kevin
about your department listen this is
very traumatic just as lay people
watching it and we've heard from the
eyewitnesses how traumatic and chaotic
it was for them we've also learned that
an officer has been killed what can you
tell us about your officers and
listening to that that very dramatic
audio how they're doing how they're
feeling right now I know it's a job I
got that and you have to be stoic but
what are you all saying amongst
yourselves to be very candid with you we
really haven't had an opportunity to sit
down with one another that long enough
to figure out what it is that in one
state and what another back and no doubt
you know 50 people on our watch is not
something that we take very lightly and
what I can tell you though for my own
personal observation is that our
officers acted very heroically in this
particular event they saved a lot of
lives they were able to get people out
of the line of fire get them behind a
large block wall that was there
I think these stories will take a number
of days for us to sort these things out
and not all that interested in that
piece of it just yet but I'm
particularly interested in is keeping
our thoughts and prayers with these
victims and their families Kevin what
have you been able to find from the
mesquite residents the retirement
community where Stephen paddock lived
what I can tell you about all of our
state local and federal systems have
been check to be not sounding derogatory
information in other words been found
anything that that would indicate to us
why he took the actions that he took
obviously that's a huge part of this
investigation they need to determine you
know what this guy's motive was what
what was is try and how long you been
playing at all those types of things I'm
not aware I do know we are at the
mesquite residents
obviously it takes a little while to get
up there some Las Vegas about it oh I
guess about an hour drive and so we've
got better luck there and we continue to
we have appropriate teams up there it's
all rise they make in Surrey and they
will hopefully discover a number of
fully that help us answer some of these
questions you know we understand that
this this is a very fluid situation but
we do know this that he was 64 years old
that he lived in a retirement community
so Kevin when you hear that what did you
make of that when you heard that piece
of information about the suspect who was
who was now apparently committed suicide
it's just it's just unbelievable really
I mean none of it really makes sense you
know maybe we should have known
maybe we could have talked right now
there's no indications of that a 64 year
old man goes on a homicidal rage killed
over 50 people you know you want to have
the answers to those questions we intend
to get those answers the best we can but
it just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever is the Mandalay Bay Hotel
being fully cooperative with
investigators and what have they told
you what have you found out about his
behavior we know he's checked into the
hotel of her since September 28th has
absolutely been very cooperative they're
tested we enjoy those relationships here
in Las Vegas anyway they haven't forget
number cameras as you don't know we can
see me to go back through all that video
evidence that would possibly Janice you
know hurry here trying to determine you
know they're not whether or not he was a
lone actor or not and so we've had great
level of participation not only some
hotel casino industry across the board
but all of our local law enforcement
police fire and EMS have just works
together really really well like I said
before we trained for this it's still
something that you hope there's never
gonna happen will happen now that would
need to figure out why well you do you
mentioned that you trained for it but
you certainly I would
imagine don't think it's going to happen
at a country music festival headlined by
Jason Aldean
how are you processing that part of the
story as you well know Las Vegas hosts a
significant number of special events
really almost there's not a day that
goes by that we don't have something
large going on here in Las Vegas so we
have a lot of experience with these
types of events and in fact I wouldn't
consensus Aaron even call this this
event a large event for our scene but I
can tell you that I don't know how you
change for a man with automatic rifle
fire from the 32nd floor of a casino
that's firing down into a very large
crowd across the street so well
obviously you've got to go back to the
drawing board I remember these things
but we got a long way to go on that and
I just make that point though is the
citizens that were there and the police
that were there they all works very well
together to save life you're looking at
live pictures right now Kevin as we
speak to you on the air our viewers are
seeing pictures of that window that was
apparently shot out on the 32nd floor of
the Mandalay Bay a casino those pictures
coming in via helicopter Kevin I we know
that you've located now Stephen paddocks
wife who was out of the country has she
been able to give you any information we
are actively working to contact her and
we will continue to work at that and see
also whether there are other family
members that we can receive any
information from as we continue invest
so just so I understand you you located
her out of country but you haven't
spoken to her yet what is the where do
you think she is I share that
information just yet well we heard you
say that he did use Stephen paddock used
his own ID to check into the hotel there
have been reports that he used his
wife's ID for other things do you know
how his wife's ID was used in this
particular story
the only thing that I'm aware of any
identification being used was that there
was a gaming club SWAT club that casinos
use and that he had one point was using
that card to gamble with so that's the
only piece of identification evidence
that I'm aware of that even comes close
to get your action so he's been gambling
in the past few days at the hotel do we
know if housekeeping has entered his
room throughout his stay that's one of
the questions that we're trying to get
answered obviously you want to know how
we got those rifles up there and so
we'll continue to look into that
information as well so what's the next
step in your investigation we know this
is a very big crime scene and you have a
lot of people to interview what are the
next steps for your department now to
start investigating this particular
incident very large crime scene with
potentially upwards of 23,000 witness
even so we're in the process and have
them interviewing hundreds and hundreds
of victims were setting up a member of
hotlines so that people can provide
video to us a lot of cell phone video
that type of stuff but I think the
biggest challenge for us right now is
with the significant number of deceased
as well as injured individuals
reconciling the families with those that
are still living and you know a number
of folks are still currently in surgery
and so we'll chime that to make sure
that we have respects for those victims
and their families every day night with
one another with that meanwhile you have
a significant effort some of
investigative standpoint not
partnerships with the FBI and local law
enforcement here and we continue to go
through and anticipate that will take us
you know into the evening before we're
able to wrap up the actual various
different crime scenes and tourism and
business events is a major part of the
economy there in the city you talk about
the even 22,000 isn't the largest number
for a crowd size that you cover a
in Las Vegas how prepared is the city
going forward tomorrow to di't where you
still have concerts scheduled and you
still have many people of different
hotels there for different events yep
you're right and obviously the next
couple of days you have to make sure
that we have a sense of security here in
our city so we've actually mobilized on
our 12-hour shifts rosters so I have a
significant number of officers available
and we'll continue to work on that and
not not only have other local law
enforcement stepped up to the plate to
assist the FBI as well so we're fine
when it comes to that and we'll be
prepared Kevin is there any other
information you can give us about the
citation that Steven paddock received or
his any of his encounters or
conversations with local police I can
confirm to you that he received the
citation I actually didn't even ask that
it was for but when I was talking about
it doesn't have any impact on didn't
leave any impact on the officer who
issued that citation so I believe it was
for speeding is what I'm being told but
no he didn't didn't stick out at
anybody's mind and even I can't recall
actually you know the word we heard from
Sheriff Joe Lombardo was no information
was derogatory and kudos to Sheriff Joe
Lombardo what can you tell us about him
certainly you know he's a local
enforcement guy who all the sudden has
put on a national stage
the sheriff's image they're elected
before your turn then this is a never
one of those things in law enforcement
that you ever want to be thrust onto the
national stage yes but I agree with you
I think that masterfully and the men and
women of the organization and just
served great great rides great valor and
really respects when you see and as a
story continues to develop I think
you'll be
impressed by a number of things that not
only law enforcement did but the
citizens as well this lives out there
well under sheriff as Sheriff Joseph
Lombardo said nobody is paid to do what
we are experiencing right now you're
you're having to suffer and and to
grieve you've lost as well in your
community there while protecting others
who are at that concert so we appreciate
your time thank you so much